normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
Newsweek Disney faces renewed boycott
calls it's not just Disney but I love
how this made it to Newsweek they say
things are heating up for Disney with
the company facing fresh boycott calls
continuing on from its announcement that
the brand was ceasing advertising with X
formerly Twitter just days ago several
leading Global Brands including Disney
announced their we we we get they're
boycotting boycotting X Elon Musk then
said go f yourself
and in response to this we got a bunch
of people on X posting photos of them
canceling their Disney plus
subscriptions now I just want to stress
I canceled mine a long time ago after
Disney Plus thank to the security forces
in China who are running the weer
concentration camps where they force
women to get abortions and let's just
say that is it is very very brutal what
they're doing to those people so uh I'm
not I'm not too happy with what Disney's
doing and I don't want them to have my
money but now it's piling up they're
also calling for boycotts of all of
these other companies so it'll be
interesting will will X be able to
survive just off of subscription
memberships I kind of feel like how much
is the the ad revenue for how much is
100 million a
year Andrew Tate said he would do a mill
didn't you say You' do so he said he'd
do a million a month million a month to
advertise X 100K a month I said 100K a
month for three months and I think he
said a mill so we have another Mill can
we
a they were doing 250,000 a month but
they doubled it to 500,000 so then
you're talking about 50 mil a year after
stuff like that and it's probably closer
to 30 mli year where it's like I think a
guy like him doesn't really care that
much about that type of numbers yeah I
wonder what they're going to do I
thought maybe that they would end up
shuttering this centralized service and
turn into a decentralized protocol
because they've been talking a lot about
using Noster and he's been working with
Jack Dy uh Elon Noster is like uh what
was your question I was I was saying who
who's using yeah yeah that they would
like join the fediverse and then make
Twitter X more of a protocol that you
would use like a decentralized
peer-to-peer communication system so
like we'd all host it on our devices and
if like half of them go down the system
still running on everybody else's device
you just poured in so it would cut the
cost of servers and I don't know what
their bulk costs are I know when he
bought the company slash a bunch of the
employee count this is actually a really
good point this this could be a clever
play for Elon where they finally get
Twitter onto a decentralized system
where no one can be banned ever again he
says we're not even it's not even up to
us yeah so if they go I I I don't know
if you're saying Noster Noster yeah but
or or what's the other one uh um the
fediverse mhm the ferse so these are
like protocols where anyone can plug
into any other one basically like the
internet if Elon Musk says Twitter is
now going to be open source and
Federated that means you could be signed
up for gab and tell someone oh if you're
follow me you know Ryan gab.com and then
if someone's on X they can type that in
and follow you wherever they are so this
would mean that X Twitter whatever could
no longer ban anybody wouldn't that be
like destroying his investment though
like the if the company is going to go
under because Advertiser is canceled
yeah and then he's just like well the
company's dead unless we open source and
Federate also if you open source you
could put stuff in where if if there is
advertisement for every million dollars
Disney pulls another censorship person
gets fired and just have that trigger
set up and just be like well it's up to
you it's not out of my control right now
the thing set up HR person goes for 100
grand and a million dollars we go a
censorship person oh like smart
contracts smart contract just triggers
firings according to how much money
Disney pulls sort of hold them hostage
on that leverage I kind of get the vibe
that this is the direction Not only
would it be great for Humanity to have a
a system like Twitter or X whatever you
want to call it on the fediverse I mean
that's the big deal you got mines and
Mastadon and things like that on the
ferse gab you mentioned earlier but Elon
has blatantly stated he's not in it for
the money and he never was he's in it
for Humanity and free speech and things
like that I bet his investors are like
yeah
we're we're kind of
the CEO had to come up with the
statement being like well we really
liked Elon he again like he has a lot of
investors who probably like
yeah Humanity but you could also run ads
on a decentralized service there's no
need that it would ever really even
disrupt the ad revenue and then actually
he could come out and say we're going to
decentralize the service Federate which
means we're not going to be responsible
for any hate speech because it's out of
our hands and we can still control
advertising so we can make all the money
with none of the downside that's a play
right there would it mean if you
Federated that the advertisements get
seen by more people too theoretically
that's an interesting concept probably
not Federated advertising is a nice way
to go in the future it is but he would
have to so basically the way that would
work is the idea of Federated social
media is imagine if like how the
internet works you can open a browser
and go to any website you would be a
member at on X and you could choose to
follow any other Federated account from
any other website so let's say you know
you're on X and someone's on Facebook
you could you could go on to X and
follow someone's Facebook but the owners
of x if they're in the FED could say we
want to Blacklist all accounts from
facebook.com and then you can't see it
through the Facebook node but if you go
to like Mastadon you can still see the
Facebook node list they get to choose
where something like nostr is way more
open and you can't stop anything but you
I think it's fair that that a service
can say we don't want to connect to the
service that's fine but if Elon was
selling ads on X they would not appear
outside of X but if he federates you
could sign up for I don't know truth
social if truth social Federated you
could follow Trump on
from his truth Social account so like it
basically connects does truth social
have to allow it though yes okay so so
truth which I isn't truth Mastadon it
was based on Mastadon I can't imagine
they're going to want to though because
isn't that the whole reason that Trump's
not tweeting is because he has they want
to make money they want to make money
and they're like you can't go over to
our competitors the big the bigger
question I have for you guys cuz you
guys make a a a deeply deeply offensive
and shocking edgy content is I mean what
do what do what do you think about these
companies I mean Disney recently
announced that they line with the public
one of the problems with like companies
like Disney in general sort of like Coke
where you go even if someone goes oh I'm
going to boycott that and you go just so
you know they own all all the other 45
others like you it's impossible to even
remember who they own and stuff like
that right this it's very I bet you Coke
does or someone yeah probably you know
you seen the thing where it's like three
companies own every
single they own ESPN they own I mean my
main issue with Disney is I'm banned
from all their parks for life but uh
story story
well you're not the bottom line is
streaking is a nighttime
activity no uh I don't know I don't I
don't really watch any Disney stuff like
I'm not like into Star War like you guys
watch like Star Wars like the
Mandalorian I only watched on and that
stuff after episode one came out I L
they made like a ton of movies where you
don't even realize that was a Disney F I
was done with Mandalorian when they
fired Jano I'm like dude if you so and
that's the start of it but when they so
I had a year membership and then I
bought the year in advance when they
when they when the weager Muslim thing
came out where they thanked this
security Force I'm like yo those people
are like mercilessly torturing human
beings and we all know so I'm not I'm
done with this and then with Mandalorian
I mean Gina corano that whole stuff I
was like this company's garbage yeah the
crazy thing is like their stock is not
doing well so you think that they
actually is the whole reason that Bob
Iger got brought back is cuz he was
going to you know stop all this nonsense
I feel like that was the whole thing is
that Bob Iger the other guy went in
right that guy was tanking it and then
he sort of came back from the grave
being like I'm
so I feel like to some degree he being
he probably will put kind of an end to
some of the stuff but obviously but it's
probably just ceremonial right they're
saying oh look board members we have
brought Bob back and so things will be
okay he never actually committed to
changing any ideology well I bet with
the movie like cuz all their movies keep
bombing but like the thing is like those
Cycles is those movies probably went
into development four years ago when
probably at the time you go like oh yeah
this stuff is going to be around forever
we're going to all this raw ra stuff
great idea yeah there's a great idea
right now and nobody's thinking
everyone's going to watch Marvel's 40
times yeah exactly yeah if if it came
out today it would be a huge hit and
then and now I watched it 35 times and
they probably their production schedule
is like yeah this will be out like 2022
and then it gets pushed back two years
or whatever a year and then people are
like this sucks I I just want to point
out this is made by it's it's owned by
the private company Spindrift and it's
founder they have 105 employees and you
grew up on a farm in Massachusetts I
think that's what they said and so uh
dig a little further that guy's last
name is Pepsi yeah they took a $29
million investment from and Company LLC
in 2020
drifted by vmg Partners so those are the
two big companies that came where where
do I find that that was on Wikipedia
history yeah oh really yeah subsidary of
a subsidary I mean they are SOL product
that's what they do that's what they do
they like Starbucks this I I read this
in the newspaper so maybe it's not true
but my understanding is Starbucks will
open a coffee shop and called like Mom
and Pops and then you go they like oh I
don't want to go to Starbucks and you're
actually buying from Starbucks yeah I
got you Starbucks is my favorite one how
they play all this stuff cuz a lot of
times they'll do you know some super
Progressive thing about like refugees
and then people get mad and then they
replace it with veterans and they get
mad and they replace it back with
refugees they go back and forth between
refugees and Veterans trying to find the
sweet spot so the company moles and
Company LLC is a publicly traded
multinational investment firm so there's
is very likely Black Rock State Street
and Vanguard are involved we got we got
to check we got to check 20 minutes yeah
we should we should check no Enjoy your
black rock beverage whatever you put
money in smooth Taste of Black Rock I
can wait wait let me TR that's a good
name for a
drink it tastes like a young Millennial
couple losing a bit on their first home
yeah yeah but let's let I'll look into
it while my tastes like foreclosure
that's my favorite flavor
yeah that's so fun so anyway your cool
hip beverage is owned
by what about liquid we got liquid death
over here too are they I hear they're
they are based AF perhaps I don't know
yeah I think so I think they're pretty
yeah I don't think they've gone public
yet I think they're talking about going
public but uh I don't think they have
you guys want to know a secret I heard
the liquid death was partially on by the
Clinton
Foundation you guys want to know a
secret so liquid death is you pour them
out and just put top water in give it to
your guess it says no no it says death
of plastic on those cans yeah look I
like liquid death but there's plastic in
those cans okay plastic and cans all
cans are lined with PL oh they lining so
if you take it's what everyone used to
say to Pamela Anderson there's plastic
in those
cans nice but if if you if you uh uh
take something that will eat away the
metal it leaves a plastic bag yeah and
and you'll see the drink in the plastic
bag and you can oh the the coating yeah
the whole inside is coated so we
actually did it my brother did the skin
from the lizard people that's how that's
that's how they make your canned beever
this is disconcerting the sixth
ingredient on here is adreno Chrome so
nice no liquid death actually pretty
good yeah it's also like fairly based
low sugar I like yeah it's also like
when the reason you about to have
Plastics when it's in the Sun so keeping
it out of the Sun supposedly negates it
that's what I've heard thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net